And welcome all of you guys to this open
agent hackathon online round for all of
us. Um where I hopefully
you can all integrate the Uniswap API
and just like you know use us and LP
points in your application in minutes.
My name is Angela as Audrey mentioned.
Um I do developer relations at Uniswap
Labs. And
So I would love to start by saying most
of the crypto and fintech products needs
to swap. And this is just chatting about
crypto and fintech products, but if we
talk about the theme of this hackathon,
agents needs to swap. Agents needs to
pay. So today I just want to you show
you some of the possibilities that we
can you know allow you to integrate in
your agent without
you know like creating all or or
building all of the routing
infrastructure, all of the swap
infrastructure. Just like couple of
clicks and you're set to go. The Uniswap
API powers on-chain swaps for wallets,
exchanges, fintechs, AI agents, and
more.
From routing to liquidity aggregation as
I mentioned and execution price should
be super easy to and straightforward to
app
you know to add in all of our and your
products. The reason why is because the
Uniswap API aggregates on-chain and
off-chain liquidity across all of our
protocols. Uniswap V2,
Uniswap V3, Uniswap V4, but also Uniswap
X and more than 25 market makers. So
yeah, this gives us a lot of like space
and room for you guys to get quotes
and also price execution. Some like key
stats to share here and there. The
Uniswap protocol cumulative volume more
than four
trillion.
Uniswap protocol all-time trades more
than 2.7 billion. Uniswap protocol
assets more than 10 billion than 10
million. And on the API side of the
equation you have more than 17 chains to
integrate. Um and yeah, 97%
fill rates for all of you. As I
mentioned, there's plenty of spaces for
you to
integrate, but the reality is like I
mentioned at the beginning, you should
be able to integrate this in minutes and
it's that easy as go to
developers.uniswap.org
that org, generate your API key, request
the code, get the best price, and
customize your full model because we
don't charge any fees, but you set all
of the rules. And yes, when I said
request the code, get the best price,
you can do this manually, but you can
also use Uniswap AI or AI these days to
make this even easier. As some ideas or
use cases, our bounty for this hackathon
is super simple, like crazy simple. We
want you to integrate the Uniswap API
and all of your agents' ideas.
And yeah, best creative case wins and
the best application or integration
wins. What I would love to ask you all
here is like we're looking for for great
feedback. So we're going to um
you know appreciate if you add any
feedback MD file in your submissions in
order for us to understand how was your
experience, how can we improve, is there
something that you missed building this
or yeah, anything that you like that you
like to to to have moving forward. For
example, back in the day I did to a
mobile um can some of you guys asked us
for having the LP endpoint. This is now
live just a few weeks after. So if you
guys keep pushing and giving us a lot of
feedback, we're able to move forward and
add all of these features in our
ecosystem. So pretty straightforward,
$5,000 in prizes, best Uniswap API
integration. And the possibilities are
you know honestly infinite from trading
applications to agent-based systems,
automated strategies, and even new
financial primitives. So what we're
looking is like show us what you could
build and yeah, moving forward from this
hackathon, what is something that you
like to see out there and that your
agents can run for you. So yeah, as for
resources, there are like simple stuff
that I like to share the developer
platform developers.uniswap.org
which is launched this and you should be
able to find everything you need there.
From documentation to your API keys to
API references to a lot of like Uniswap
um to AI
features, everything should be there. If
not, let me know in the feedback. Hey
Angela, you know what, you guys missed
this. Add it into the
developers.uniswap.org.
Here or here, super simple. But also we
have Uniswap AI skills. This is what I'm
going to show you right after this.
Super simple. Honestly, I just created
like a like a small
mockup in order for me to
add in my Anthropic API key, my Uniswap
API key, and also like of course my
wallet key using base mainnet to swap,
get a quote, and swap. Super simple. But
yeah, this skill should be able to let
you build even faster during this time.
So yeah, let's try it out. As I
mentioned, developer platform is the
way. So if this is the best place,
developers.uniswap.org,
here as I mentioned, you're going to
find Let me actually share my screen
like this.
Um here actually you should be able to
find
again API references so you could test
your API
quotes here, set all of your parameters,
and see like oh yeah, this might work in
my project or not. We have LP endpoint
as I mentioned and
many other things. We have plenty of
resources and as I mentioned like
different content for all of you guys in
here. Also on the ecosystem side of the
equation, back in the day I can remember
some of you guys
requesting me like hey Angela, where can
I find funding information, where can I
find GTM support, where can I find
security resources? Everything in here.
Um
And if you want to check the swapping or
AI content should be
here pretty straightforward. Okay, so I
need an API key. That's the first thing
that I'm going to do. And then I need
the Uniswap AI skills that I honestly
just added previous to this
which should be because I wanted to you
know spend the least time possible. But
super simple.
Um
You go to Claude code if you if you use
Claude code or just like install this in
your terminal and you should be able to
get access to all of these plugins. The
one that I recommend you guys to use
here is the plugin
Uniswap trading that integrates all of
the swap integration. By swap
integration means using the API. Of
course using the the swap
endpoint, the LP one, but also pay with
any token using the export to. So if
your agent has any payment
possibilities, this is also
a great chance for you.
I set up a wallet before this using
base mainnet and this is basically the
developers.uniswap.org
that I mentioned. She goes here on the
API key. I created one open agent for
sure and I just set up my
my Claude with like an M file where I
just added the Anthropic API key, the
Uniswap API key, and of course my
private key from this wallet that again
I'm going to use as a test. Previous to
this talk, I just charged like two or
three dollars and then I did a swap.
42 minutes. I honestly chat with my um
with my
with my Claude in Spanish just because
it is like my native language, but yeah,
it should be pretty straightforward.
It's like use uh let's let's I want to
swap ETH to USDC on base mainnet. Let's
swap
0.5
uh USD. And let's see how it goes. As I
mentioned, what I requested to Claude
before this is like you know what, I
want an MVP where I can just give you
these keys and an M file and then
I am able to get a quote, request it,
and then swap, and you know visualize
this here. Of course you can add more of
these things, but yeah, it should be
pretty straightforward. To add the
plugins that I mentioned, you just go to
/plugins and then look for Uniswap. I
already have all of these installed, but
this is for you to um have a little bit
more of context in here.
Um
Do do do.
So okay. Uh I am asking Claude that I
want to swap ETH to USDC on mainnet
and then what it's doing is using the
chain ID that I just set up on my M
file. It's saying like yeah, chain is
the base mainnet. I set up this like dry
run mode just because I didn't want it
the agent to swap because they allow I
want to like some permit to
issue some permissions first and then
this is a conversion. Um so now it's
getting the quote. Use the Uniswap API
to get the quote and then execute the
trade.
Um and yeah, this is pretty pretty much
it. Uh should be again pretty
straightforward for you guys to interact
with.
Um and if you have any questions during
this hackathon, what I'm going to do is
to spend all of my time on Discord from
now on.
Um and yeah, hopefully guiding you
throughout the whole the whole the whole
hackathon. Um and if I have more info
here, no, just honestly my
um
my information and where you guys can
find me. But as I mentioned, if you go
to Discord, uh the ETHGlobal one on the
partners Uniswap Foundation one, I'll be
there. And that should be it. Let me let
me see if Claude already like fits
thinking, you know, sometimes it takes
some time here and there.
But yeah, use all of these
AI
features that we now have to, you know,
empower your agent to to swap any
network out there. So now it's verifying
the the balance, disabling the the the
drive on block that I just did, execute
the swap via the agent and stuff like
that. So
thank you all. That's that's it for for
for this hackathon.
Amazing. Um, did you want to have some
time for a Q&A?
For like maybe the final 10 minutes?
Yeah, if anyone has any questions, happy
to happy to jump. And for now I can show
this if like the cloud is making is able
to do it in like, you know, 5 minutes.
Sometime it takes some time, so yeah.
Okay, great. And feel free to raise your
hand, guys. Or you can also post your
questions just right in the chat here.
Are we good? I think I saw Elena asking
me on TG. I was out of office yesterday,
but um
but I'll follow up today. And the
question for George is like, do you have
any testnet support? It was mentioned in
the docs by Sepolia I support it. The
The The answer is yes.
Um, but there's some things that you
might have to make sure in order to get
ports. If not, you're going to get some
errors. So
pretty much, let me Should be here.
Pretty much, it's important that
whenever you're setting up Sepolia
pools, you need to have at least um
$300 for the L2s.
And a thousand on the mainnet if you
don't have to like it, that's okay. But
for for the L2s, it's important to have
at least this
on the pool so that that that that it
goes to to get the coding instead of
like getting the four of four of four
error that you might be getting or 501.
I don't know if that's helpful for Yeah,
that's the the troubleshooting there.
I'm in.
And finally, swap completed, by the way.
Yes. No, I just want to say that the
message sent in Discord, I created a
group with with Hulu. I think you
already responded there.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I checked your TG message. It was
about the idea with
Yeah.
I I actually I Yeah, yeah, yeah. So
yeah, I already checked that message
message. Yeah, my question has been
answered, so that's all.
Lovely. Lovely. Yeah,
like to be honest, guys, I was a hacker
before and I I know how hard it is to,
you know, get out there and having
questions and no one to answer. So
that's why during this hackathons I
really give my best to, you know, like
be there out there available and and be
there for you guys.
On Discord, as I mentioned, I didn't get
the the time to answer yet, but I'll
follow up after the meeting and call me
in. If you have any troubleshooting or
whatever, let me know. But most
important, if you can give me feedback
in that uh feedback.md file in your
repo, dude, I'll be more than happy to,
you know, work after after after this
hackathon to improve the experience. So
yeah.